[Music]
[Music]
mmm
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we
sieve through philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use in
your
everyday life hi i'm dan hayes and i'm
joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler and today we're
talking about
memory and truth so these are some
pretty big
topics and we have a little story before
we get started
which is relying on memory and hopefully
true memories
about how dan and i picked these we we
actually had
something kind of cool this this uh last
uh what weekend yeah it was saturday
um we got to meet up face to face for
the first time
in over a year yeah for
14 months i think maybe since the last
time we were in the same place at the
same time but you know
now uh covid we've got a lot of
restrictions lifted you know and we're
both inoculated and so we could
hang out on milwaukee's riverwalk and
we got to talking about what should we
do for our next
show topic and dan had this idea so why
don't you
kind of take it away about the origin of
that and i'll correct you if you get any
if you remember anything wrong
um so like memory is always kind of this
fickle thing that we
uh encode it uh once especially during
every night we sleep and our our brain
kind of decides what's actually useful
to keep long-term
and what's not and kind of throws it
away um
and i'd actually gone through an entire
um
course in college that was kind of about
um
memory and so i already had all these
notes kind of like rattling out from the
back of my head i also have a physical
notebook of them
on so you know once again there's
interesting what do i remember
and then going back to my notebook and
like oh i kind of remember that
differently
um but uh it was this
you know especially in consideration of
truth like
what what do we remember to be truth
what is truth and how are we
certain of this truth especially when we
are oftentimes relying on this very
uh lossy and falsifiable uh
faculty but we feel so incredibly
convinced whenever we say something that
it is actually true
yeah and conviction is oftentimes if you
have too much of it that might actually
be a sign that
what you're working with is less
straight out memory of the facts or the
truth and much
more something something built up
something that has been fed to you or
the world gave to you and you interpret
it in a certain way or you know
when you're really invested in it you
always have to ask the question why am i
so
emotionally connected with this and
that's not to say that we should you
know
suddenly become skeptics now we don't
remember anything
we don't want to put that on to anybody
through this but
there are a lot of things that we we can
bring philosophy to bear and psychology
and some other fields to
to uh try to make sense of maybe even
literature too i mean think about proust
and his uh memory books
their you know his his ideal was to
i don't know basically write all all the
things that that he recalled from the
past i only made it through the first
one before i abandoned the project of
reading them i don't know did you ever
read those
i i did not but yeah i do have my own
you know journals which uh you know
probably not nearly as in detail as
proust but
uh very interesting to go back and read
are they journals in the sense of
diaries where you
you like said what happened that day or
are they
are they more like resolutions or things
um
they're mostly um
[Music]
like when something has come to a point
where i feel like
i need to either write to myself to it
in order to just kind of get it out of
my head
and think about it in a different way
but definitely
um almost never did i have a daily
journal
um except for when i was doing some like
uh stoic end of day type thing but
that still wasn't like that much of a
total recall of the day was like okay
what was
good or bad how what actions were good
or bad in that day
well this is actually a good point to
jump in
right memory is so often
not like just a complete blanket
remembering everything that happened
it's usually focused
on on something some sort of
highlight yeah it's not i i wanted to
say practical but it's not always
something practical i mean we can try to
remember you know what happened in this
movie that we saw
as a kid or we can get into all sorts of
digressions but we could we can also
things like trying to remember where the
hell did i put
my car keys you know and you try you
read you retrace your steps in your head
right
um or or my coffee cup you try to
yeah a coffee cup could be bad that way
too i mean we could probably have also
we could talk about lost
objects in in general uh require us to
to engage in in memory to make it active
and then other people try to help us out
and they're not usually helping us out
very much they're actually you know
suggesting things we're like yeah i
already checked there i already thought
about that
you know and they impede our ability to
to get there and we
all have that experience of having some
phrase on the tip of our tongue we're
trying to remember it
and then we we can't in the situation
that we want to be in
and then we we remember it later on
right
right uh and
so i guess we should really talk about
like what are some ideas or at least
early ideas of
what memory is and and kind of uh
the debate they're in versus of on
uh kind of nature or nurture or nativism
or
um i it's on the tip of my tongue
the empiricism right yeah and yes having
a tabula rasa
yes so thank you for helping me out
there greg
uh to remember it
so um the tabula rasa is a
blank slate or an erased slate uh first
uh appearing in aristotle's de anima i
believe that's on the soul correct
exactly yeah yeah and he's trying to
talk about what is
what is memory how does it work and how
is it connected with these other
faculties like imagination
and sensation and all those sorts of
things
and so you put sort of this idea of a
blank state a kind of a pure empiricist
idea that everything that's coming to us
is from our sense
data you know what we can see and feel
and touch and smell
and this is then imprinted upon
this slate or i guess on in his
understanding of like a
a waxed tablet not quite
yeah that was a very common idea in in
ancient times that wax tablet actually
that got used into medieval times
you would often write a composition
on it's almost like an etch-a-sketch
right or
uh nowadays we have those uh apps that
allow us to like draw on our phones or
tablets
it's like that you would do your
preliminary work
on the wax tablet because it was you
know
you could erase it you could you could
always do it over
and then once it was in the shape that
you wanted then you would turn it to
like whatever
ink was going to go on to parchment
paper papyrus
pick whatever whatever it happens to be
and then you would you would write that
out so it was
it was like a like a stop gap right
your rough draft exactly your scratch
paper we used to call it right
literal scratch paper um and you'd erase
it by heating
up so the wax would melt back into a
flat uh
sheet and then you could go right back
at it um
and uh oh
i remember what yes well
xeno the stoic talked about he used that
metaphor too of
uh wax and he would talk about the
impressions or imp
or appearance of the fontasia as
sort of like a seal onto the wax
in in our minds and then you know they
would they would stay there until we
until we got rid of them or another
analogy is like
writing in the sand and unless we
uh intend to uh transfer that into
long-term memory
though uh the ocean will come
up to the beach and and wash it away and
so you you
this is kind of like an analogy for like
maybe working memory or the memory of
your day
before it turns into long vocabulary uh
yeah
but this is kind of indirect contrast
with like a lot of
plato's like ideas of the forum if we
already know all these things that
and we're just coming to recognize them
within ourselves
well that's an interesting one because
plato thinks that we
only very dimly remember them
and we need um we need things to jog our
memory
so so we need dialectic you know the
back and forth
discussion of things we need we need to
see examples
and it takes a long time before we can
get her
we can bring that out of memory this is
something too i always talk with my
students i say when we're like reading
the meno or the republic where he talks
about
the forms and i say do you think he
means this for
you know it's clear that he thinks it
applies to mathematics and geometric
proofs and things like justice and
courage and you know
what we could call metaphysics and and
morals
but do you think he means this about
like
how to make a ham sandwich or how to tie
your shoes
you know there's got to be a lot of
things that there's no forms for those
we learn
those like think about tying our shoes
right but why isn't there a perfect form
of a ham sandwich
it's it's not the sort of thing that you
could have a perfect form of in plato's
ontology now
there there might be other people who
come up with a similar kind of theory
because they they often talk about you
know the platonic form of this
the platonic form of that but the
platonic form is um
it's very um
oh it's an essence but it's also
featureless
like if you think about the platonic
form of human being this this often
blows my students minds
you know i say so imagine a human being
and
it doesn't have any particular color of
its skin or its eyes
and it does have two eyes because that
that's part of our essence
and it's rational but it's neither male
nor female
or anything else and you know
that there's that part and then the
forms this is one of aristotle's
criticisms of it
they don't do a hell of a lot you know
the the platonic form of
human being never actually does any
human activities
right it doesn't pick its nose it
doesn't scratch itself
it doesn't stuff its face with ham
sandwiches
[Music]
it's just out there in in form land
doing whatever
forms do you know same thing with the
form of justice the form of justice
this is one reason i'm not a platonist
[Laughter]
the form of justice itself it's like
perfect justice but
it doesn't do anything so i think
aristotle's right to say okay well this
doesn't
this doesn't really help us much so
lovely digression
uh coming back to like this is a whole
nativism versus empiricism kind of had
continue on
you know throughout the centuries um to
like our nature versus nurture debates
of like how do we grow as individuals
how do we learn how do we
gather information and and you know
at least what we've seen the last you
know i guess a couple hundred years now
is that it's it's really both there are
yeah both exactly innate structures
within ourselves and there are and
a lot of it is um uh
nature and uh and i guess i've i've
um my current oh go ahead
my my current favorite theory is that we
have kind of like
a or at least a analogy of it is that
we're kind of like
we're a chapter book and we've got like
a really really rough outline
okay of of the chapters and
depending upon our
uh nature are the things that we've
experienced
some chapters get filled in more than
others
okay yeah yeah that makes that that's a
that's a good analogy i think
um i also kind of think that there's
there's quite a few things that are
that are rooted in our nature and
they're kind of rough
sort of like what you're talking about
is a chapter book where you get the
outlines and then you got to kind of
fill things in
but i think there's a lot that if you
don't have the right kind of experiences
they're not going to get
actuated they're not going to get put
into play
you know and maybe there's maybe there's
some of these that we we still don't
um know about or we've only dimly
dimly glimpsed at this point in time
maybe maybe there's more
development for humanity um i hope so
in the future yeah
i mean that's that's a good point
there's a lot of thing
there's a lot of ways in which we could
be doing much better right
but let us not uh devolve into um
so yeah or just pure pessimism
there's lots to look forward to we have
lots of problems but
i have confidence that hopefully we as a
species can
move forward yeah so
you one of the things that you wanted to
talk about is how memory actually
works though right yeah how it proceeds
so whenever we actually recall a memory
the the process you know thank you
neuroscience at least for
the small amounts that we've been able
to glean from the human mind even though
it's
we are still you know a small boat at a
vast sea here
um but uh the pathways
write each other every time that we
recall a memory
and so this is how you kind of get big
fish stories because every time
your your uncle says oh yeah i bought it
i got a fish this big and the next
time's like i got a fish this big and i
got a fish
all of a sudden you've got like a fish
that's like you know the size of the
titanic
and and he might think he might be
embellishing a little bit every time
yeah but every time that he
embellishes it he is actually helping to
rewrite his memory of
what the actual fish was and then and
especially if you keep on doing this
over and over
um the uh
amount that it moves from the ground
truth
um can become these very large uh
discontinuities yeah you could talk
about there's the narrative fish and
then there's the fish that actually
did get caught right and the narrative
fish is what is
changing but you're saying that as it's
changing it's still anchored to
that original fish that got caught
unless your uncle just made it up all
together you know
which which sometimes does happen too
people can have memories of things that
never took place um you know a lot of
a lot of quotes are like this you know
you people
not just with like famous people in the
past where there's all sorts of fake
quotes circulating around on the
internet
um but even with lines and movies that
we think were
said in that movie that that something
close to it might have gotten said
but nobody ever said that and somehow we
all have this collective memory that
you know luke skywalker said this or
uh who else should we pick out like
indiana jones maybe i don't know which
which quotes would be um
what is it um the spice must flow from
dune
does not appear in the film oh
interesting but it is in the book right
or isn't it i don't think it's an either
but it became
this like collective
what is that hallucination and becoming
so ingrained into the society
that it is a thing or i guess what's the
line
on uh nodes or uh what's uh
luke i am your father right is not
actually the line
yeah isn't it amazing that that can
happen
you know or beam me up scotty that's
another one right
uh correct doesn't say that apparently
in in star trek stuff
or um although he must have said it at a
lot of conventions i bet
but what's the um the the children's
book about the family of bears
goldilocks you mean or are you talking
about the bernstein bears yeah
the you know you mean the was it the
berenstein bears
oh is it yeah i don't know
i haven't looked at it for so long and
my kids weren't my kids weren't into
them
you know um now that i actually
that's a lot of hazy memory area like i
remember them being into the hungry
hungry caterpillar
you know and i remember good night moon
um
i don't remember an awful lot else from
what i read to my kids
i remember trying to get them into alice
in wonderland and then
them not being interested in that either
speaking of good night moon there's a
great parody called i believe it's
uh good night madiba
oh it's good night ah sand worm good
night benny jesuit
good night yeah
uh okay so um so there's actually some
really interesting studies
on of of people like we were talking
about journaling and how things that
be misremembered and how we can be so
confident in our memories
that we will even disavow our previous
experiences and so um they had a group
of
um test subjects on uh have an event and
they
all wrote it down and they came back to
them a couple months later and said how
what do you remember of this event yeah
um and so
there's there's uh they've done this
many times that there's a
uh a subset of these subjects that
reject
um their own oh they're sorry
well they first say misremember the
events and then there's a subset of
that group who will then reject their
own writing about the events
even when it's written in their own
handwriting like they are
so uh and they think it's like a fake
or yeah they think like someone is
playing a trick on them because they
they believe their memory to be so
infallible
that's interesting so we we tend to
think that we
are right all the time because the
feeling of being confidently correct and
confidently correct
but incorrect feel the exact same way
it's sort of like that you know who are
you going to believe
me or your lion eyes except that in this
case
it's not your lying eyes it's your lying
memories about stuff
which which are lies
so um you're telling me that you'll
remember this next portion
of the the satanic panic of the 80s uh
what was your experience of this well i
i didn't fortunately get involved with
any of the like
accusations about you know this lurid
child abuse stuff that was going on but
i will say that that um
what do they call that that technique it
was like recovering memories that was
going on that
that applied to these these crazy
stories about like you know
which is recovering repressed memories
right yeah now that that didn't just
apply
to that that got used uh in the 80s and
the 90s
in all sorts of other venues and
many people remembered child abuse that
may or may not have happened and
quite a few people you know got brought
up on charges and someone to
to prison on the basis of testimony that
was
you know was it really a witness
testimony or victim testimony in some
cases it probably was and then in some
cases it probably wasn't and there's
this vast
domain in between where we we really
can't be sure
you know but the satanic panic was like
a particular
thing and i my my connection to it was
you know i was a metalhead
and i still am i was going to say in the
80s but um
being a metalhead back then is quite
quite different than
being into that now where you know you
go to a concert
and it's like a lot of 40 and 50 year
olds with some some younger people in
the band
might be in their their 60s or something
like that
um if they're a classic metal band and
everybody's just having a good time
in the 80s it was you know a music of
rebellion
and there was kind of a dress code denim
and leather
the old saxon song was a good depiction
of it
and you know the crowd that i ran with
quite a few of them were in fact
criminals they actually had a
joking name for at midnight sales and
services and they'd steal stuff and
fence it and
i went along as as sort of a heavy
because i was kind of big and
and a bit scary looking at the time
although i was you know really
hoping i wouldn't have to do anything
and so you know there there was like uh
there were some legitimate reasons to be
worried about what was going on with
with heavy metal and also punk you know
um and then there were there was a lot
of sort of um
well you're the outsiders you know we're
gonna say that your deviants and things
like that
and um you know if you could if you
could accuse somebody
back then of satanism um
you could actually get a lot of mileage
out of it nationwide you know nowadays
you can do that if you're kind of in the
back woods
and people buy into that sort of stuff
it's not a it's not a mainstream
idea in in in the 2020s
but in the 1980s it was this view that
oh maybe there are people out there
who are you know into sex drugs rock and
roll and also
abusing children and killing people and
all that sort of stuff
um so you had this you know kind of
let's call it a thick
narrative right and you could you could
basically make this stuff
up and then get people to think that
they
they saw something or remembered
something and it did lead to
you know some arrests and convictions
and
um you were gonna talk about a
particularly bad case where somebody
actually thought he had done horrible
things
so yeah like this entire milieu
br as well with the you know talking
about how memories rewrite themselves in
our heads
we can also implant memories so this is
like
the idea of like false memories being
implanted from this
process of recommen recovering repressed
memories
and so this is a usually been used
through a process of suggestion
they say like the the person that is
walking the individual through
this is like okay try to place yourself
at this place in your time
is your childhood or something and and
and think as vividly as possible about
this this moment
and this actually can thus stimulate
creating memories
which then you believe strongly to be
actually true
it's sort of like the use of traditional
mindfulness practices you know putting
yourself into a
a calm suggestible state and then
engaging in
visualization except in this case it's
somebody else guiding the visualization
and it's not
you know like let's get some stuff off
your shoulders it's more like let's
let's remember the horrible things that
happened to you yeah i feel like
i'm not quite sure i feel like this
might be kind of like an out shoot a
little bit of like
freud and like childhood trauma things
and trying to get that out
and um and then bring in the whole
milieu of the satanic panic at the
moment and like oh
that's you know that's interesting
because um
the freudian paradigm was
pretty much you know from like say the
30s onward into you know
late late 80s late 90s the dominant
paradigm
um and it you know like a lot of
dominant paradigms
it spun off in in many different
directions
so yeah there the notion that um
what's wrong with us is primarily
our own you know repression reaction to
working through things that happen to us
in our childhood different different
let's call them not necessarily
freudians but people working in the
shadow of freud
you know came up with different ways in
which this would would uh
would happen um so that's yeah that's
one important element of it and then
you've also got the
well if you're if it's not coming to
mind that's because you're repressing it
right
so this unfalsifiable
approach that says you know we've got
the answer and if you
question the answer you're part of the
problem right
that's yeah i mean good you're
that's just trying to repress the the
knowledge that satanists are out there
potentially
or you were a victim of of satanists and
you don't want to think that anything's
quite so scary so you want to think it
was just people being
mean to you or stuff like that when
they're really gonna kill you or rape
you or do it do whatever they're they're
gonna do yeah
yeah or you know if it's for your
parents
um how could you think that your parents
would do such horrible things to you
you know obviously you don't need
parents to be satanic to do abuse
there's lots and lots of cases of
way more cases of abuse than we ought to
have but i think a lot of people got
brought to the point where they
you know here's another thing about
memory memory works with human
activities
human activities are always ambiguous it
does somebody love you or hate you
um you might think that they love you
but maybe secretly they actually hate
you and they're just saying things
to get by or maybe they don't actually
hate you and they really secretly love
you and they're just being hard on you
it's always possible to interpret
human activities attitudes statements in
multiple ways and so when you've got
somebody kind of unscrupulous
or perhaps deluded guiding you in how
that's
uh how you should interpret it you can
get led into
all sorts of uh crazy paths right
right so um
be mindful of the people that you spend
time with i guess
to a certain extent uh so this yeah
or professionals who you you get
involved with who are going to help you
unscrew up your life right and there's a
lot of we should actually probably do a
show about
bad self-help you know
uh i i hope i put my
now i'll move from that okay um so
there's a a case a specific case about
this um
for false memories uh which is called
the thurston county
ritual abuse case as the 1988 case in
which paul ingram became convinced he
committed sexual crimes
against his own children or rather you
know reprehensible absolutely represent
reprehensible crimes um
and he was totally convinced of it to
the point where he was like confessing
um but uh there's a psychologist by the
name of
richard offshee who is a member of the
advisory board of the
false memory syndrome foundation
advocacy organization
which is rather a big mouthful but he
had
became aware of this case and he had
went down
to try to kind of unsnarl this thing
because he'd seen
the the damage that was happening from
either you know unscrupulous or just
well mining but uh thinking the wrong
things
about how to do proper psychology
and was able to run a couple experiments
with
uh richard actually with um paul and so
uh richard oshie uh claimed that
ingram's
false memories were implanted with
suggestion all she tested the
high pass hypothesis by telling ingram
that a son and daughter had accused him
of forcing them to commit incest with
each other
the interrogating officers had
previously accused ingrim of this
but he denied it and he also denied
ashi's accusation
in response ashi instructed ingram to
play
sorry prey on the idea and later ingram
produced a full
detailed written confession questioning
the daughter
who had supposed to have been involved
on despite many of these accusations
against her father she denied that she
such an incident had ever occurred a
bond being told that no such accusation
had been made by either his son or
daughter ingram refused to believe the
incident wasn't real maintaining and i
quote
it's just as real to me as anything else
ashi was thus convinced that ingram's
confessions were solely the result of
extensive interrogation sessions
and questions being applied in an
unusually suggestible individual
yeah well there there's a sort of like
hallmark case right or paradigm of how
how bad things can go
i think this does happen a lot you know
within families within
institutions oftentimes people
may not themselves be the the person
who's who's being
remembered to have done bad things may
not actually
be convinced of it like
ingram came to be but enough other
people around them believe that to be
the case
and then they're they're stuck with it
you know
the social or institutional or family
dynamic
effectively makes them into a scapegoat
right
and and i think even generally like
uh if you have got really strong
interrogation and
uh techniques by the police like
you can have this even without the whole
like um
sexual crimes and satanic panic uh yeah
you can get people to if you interrogate
them and like
deprive them of sleep and whatnot will
eventually
you know if you run through these
suggestible
uh scenarios well long enough people
might start to believe the things even
though they might have never done them
in the first place
yeah or they'll or they'll just say what
what needs to be said in order to get
out of the
bad situation you know you you remember
in
admiral stockdale's um uh discussion of
what it was like in the vietnamese
prison camps right i think he spent what
five years or
longer right he knew
that the sorts of things that they could
do
would in fact produce compliance they
would they would break him
as well as anybody else and he he
thought that it was actually
kind of a bad idea to try to turn
yourself into like you know
some sort of super person who would not
um break at all that was like a a way of
setting yourself up
but you could you could retain some sort
of you know internal
little kernel where which was still you
even while you're doing what these
other people were making you do in cases
like this that that kernel gets
cracked open too right right
yeah once once you let you know the
walls
in or the walls crumble the water rushes
in
yeah don't want to drown yourself or
your inner self
um so you know it's it's interesting i'm
i'm gonna bring up something like
totally out of
left field i've just been i just
finished
re-reading and doing some presentations
on this guy our scott backers
trilogy the prince of nothing series
each of which is around like you know
500 to 600 pages it's a fantasy epic
and in it they're sorcerers and the
sorcerers now now backer is a really
interesting guy because he was actually
a philosophy phd candidate
who had developed this whole fantasy
world out of d
but he was actually studying at
vanderbilt and he was working on his
dissertation
when he finally like published his first
novel in this
series and then after that he he just be
you know like a lot of people never
finished his dissertation
moved back home to canada and continued
writing it
and so in it he's bringing to bear he's
using fantasy as sort of a vehicle
and he actually is very self-conscious
about this in interviews he says
hey why would i if i am going to
communicate cool stuff about philosophy
and psychology
why wouldn't i use a genre that so many
people will read and so you've got
characters in there who are
engaging in some some serious
metaphysical and moral and
epistemological discourse
and there's sorcerers in it so there's
magic right and sorcery works according
to certain rules
and it has to be sung and there's all
this other stuff that i'm not going to
go into
but he talks in in one section about
cans of compulsion
and it's really the the what he has to
say is quite interesting so it with
you know a cant is a way of producing an
effect right so it's a
technique and then compulsion we think
of that as like i make you do something
right like i
i hold the gun to your uh you know
spouse's head and say
put down your gun and if you don't do it
i'll kill her right you know
it's the action movie kind of stuff or i
i blackmail you
or i appeal to your uh terrible desires
whatever it's gonna be right i
i make you do something and then backer
has one of his characters say that's not
the way it works
the way that the compulsion works is to
get
you to actually endorse this
as what it is that you want so you you
you you know might reveal information
because part of you wants to reveal that
information
part of you is cool with that and you
don't realize that that part of you has
been
manipulated has been has been touched
has been
you think it's your own self that that's
doing that and i think that's that's
kind of similar
to what we can talk about when people
have false memories and
it leads them to confess to horrible
crimes or to remember
you know grievances against people that
never actually happen that way or pick
whatever else you want
on some level we can say in some cases
we can say
this person was definitely manipulated
they were brainwashed pick whatever you
want
and then in other cases we can say no
maybe there's something in them that
wants that to be true wants that to be
the case
you know yes
you can definitely see that it reminds
me of
um i know kind of like this
uh what the old there's that quote from
lbj like you can um
uh if you convince the the lowest white
man
to believe that he's about racist
highest black man
you don't have to uh steal from him
he'll empty your pockets for you
just this idea that if you can convince
yeah
a group to um that
um that they're always above this other
class
um you can use that as a manipulating
technique to get them to do what you
want
and and as long as you can convince them
that there's this fiction that they want
to believe
um that that which satisfies
certain psychological needs like
thinking i mean if you
if you are in a society where most
people do look down upon you
you can use race or you can use gender
or you can use
immigrant status or pick whatever else
you want as the thing that you have
you know being being a native american
interestingly the first uses of the word
native american were by
white supremacists um who who wanted to
you know like talk about those
immigrants back i think it was in the
1830s or so
and how terrible things were were
getting uh
because of all of that yeah that's
actually
that's a that's a great example you
appeal to people's psychological
needs which they may not understand all
that well and you can get them to buy
into
progressively more and more radical
ideas more and more comprehensive ideas
as well
right right
so uh and just to riff off your
little thing recently there was um as a
popular piece of uh fiction there was uh
one division one of marvel's new tv
shows and i haven't watched it
but you can you can do spoilers if you
want because it's it's
i'll make it spoiler-free it doesn't
matter but in one of the latter episodes
two characters go into an extended
conversation
about the ship of theseus okay and what
makes a thing a thing
and and they're discussing it between
themselves in regards to themselves
and like what bigger platform than like
the marvel universe at this moment to
present
really kind of deep philosophical ideas
that don't usually get
a chance to be entered into our yo
zeitgeist well you know we should let's
go off of that a little bit we should
explain what the ship of theseus is for
any listeners who
don't already have some familiar
familiarity
with it right it comes from uh plutarch
originally a greek philosopher and and
he's talking about
um this this ship that uh
apparently it would go back and forth
from minos to
athens right carrying um victims
for the minotaur so what makes it the
ship of theseus other than
this guy theseus being in charge of it
why is this so important so
over time each plank of the ship of
theseus is one by one replaced as it
becomes
worn out and at some point in
time uh the last plank the last original
plank of wood is removed from the
ship of theseus now the question is
is that still the ship theseus
and then you can extend this further to
say if i took
and saved all those previous planks i'd
worn out
and reassembled a second ship of theseus
which one is the real ship of theseus is
it the
the material component of it or is it
the continuity of it
yeah and if some of the things
were replaced but they're they're
somewhat different like an oak board
instead of a pine board or something
like that does that make a difference is
it not the same ship
we can go off in all different
directions now do you think this
this ship of theseus idea could apply to
memory complexes
oh absolutely if you if you okay going
into like i guess
um we'll take a star trek
okay and so they have every once while
there are transporter
um accidents where someone might be
doubled
and so there's there's one in the next
once every 10 episodes
right so there's you know on take i
think there's a version of there's two
versions of commander riker from the
next generation timeline uh there he was
on away mission
there's a transporter malfunction he was
disintegrated and then reintegrated on
the enterprise
but then he was also reintegrated back
down to the planet
they left and so now there's two
different diverging rikers
and so they both have the exact same
memories up to that exact moment in time
and so now which one is the real riker
and so we have
another kind of like identity question
what makes the individual the individual
actually quite a few philosophers did
think that memory was
if not the one single thing that makes
us what we are
they think it's pretty central right
but then the whole discussion that we
had about how
fickle our memory is kind of just like
okay this is the one thing that makes us
who we are
but well you know what that would mean
is that the riker above and the riker
below
both have the same wrong memories
right in a lot of cases right about how
he just missed his chance with
i don't know somebody on rigel 13 that
he could have dated or whatever riker
was up to you know
yeah um he's kind of a quirky guy right
yes he's very quirky
but but you know what about memory
complexes themselves
if if
our memories are complex and they're
constructed
and they're they're you know reproducing
themselves in a way they're not just
fixed static things like pictures
in our head then parts of them could go
in and
be replaced by other bits of stuff right
and maybe over time we we don't we don't
have the same
memories but we didn't notice the
discontinuities
and so they're they're real right
yeah well they're the rules of us yeah
they're they are a
real memory but that doesn't mean that
it corresponds to reality
yeah quite true so uh you know
talking about how do we like re hold our
ourselves to some sort of grounding a
lot of us will have like mementos of our
past
either that a scrapbook or like a a
souvenir from a vacation that like helps
you jog your memory
as well as like oh yeah i definitely
went to hawaii here i have this like
little hawaiian statue that i bought at
the gift shop like that is yeah
that is definitely a a gift that that
that makes my things
true what photographs were a big way for
people to do that in the past
and i i made a big mistake myself
in in my life where i'd see people
taking photographs of all sorts of
things and i'd be like i don't need to
take photographs i've got my my memories
up in my head
you know so i'll remember this trip that
i made or this person over here
and i have very few photographs from
before i actually
got my iphone um which was about 10
years ago
my my first iphone and started taking i
mean because the phone i had before that
i could take pictures but they were just
complete garbage and actually
you know iphone 3 was was pretty garbage
too but
um you know if you hold it really really
still you could get a decent photo of
something
and i kind of regret not having saved
photos that other people took
thinking that i'll just remember it or
not taking a lot of photos myself
because i look at what i have available
in my stock of now thousands and
thousands of things that i've taken on
my phone and they they include things
like you know
um concerts that we went to or
this this time with my kids or the pets
that we have that are now gone
um and it's uh it's unfortunate not to
have that sort of stuff
um but i think in the you know 80s 90s
early 2000s i just kind of figured i
didn't i didn't need that
while other people were taking a lot of
photos
right um because those are those kind of
mementos that you're talking about right
right they are um hey but the question
is
do those things actually represent
reality themselves
and so you know you can have your
photographs and you can uh create them
in such a way that you
helps you remember but they can also be
deceptive because you're framing them in
a certain way yeah
um as well as you know we have you know
so we've since had since the
what early 1900s different levels of
you know photoshopping things like look
at the the soviet union
oh true constantly retouching photos to
like well
he wasn't ever actually part of the
party and so just really touched him out
of the thing and
i'm kind of rewriting history and so
you know there's a a wealth of really
good
um fiction about this especially from
philip k dick
that uh she's always about like what is
the nature of reality and how can we
actually be yeah prove that with what
we're experienced is reality
as a long through line of his you know
tropes that he likes to
talk about um and you know there's even
a whole thing for you know the the book
um we'll remember it for your wholesale
which became the um
major motion picture on total recall
yeah um and so they'll they'll give you
memories of a
trip to like you know to venus or mars
or whatever
and they'll actually give you physical
accoutrements that will be like oh yes
well i have this physical thing that
proves it was there
i got this at this one restaurant or
whatever
um yeah uh but you know the whole part
of the narrative is that like
these things aren't actually true things
that these are still
creations and then the it gets
way off the rails i love the book i love
the book even more than the movie
because it's so much more
yeah crazy than the book um high
recommend
well and and the irony is that
um the guy who is the main character
he he actually is like a like a super
spy or something like that right
and he's got false memories that are
keeping
his true identity repressed until he
goes in and they
do remember it for him but he he doesn't
actually
he doesn't need to have new memories
implanted because he already does
remember what it's like to be on mars
fighting guys all that sort of stuff
yeah he's he's a
uh a secret agent that has had his
mind overwritten he goes to a place that
will give him new memories he chooses
a memory that is very very close to his
actual memories which triggers his
actual memories
and thus you know craziness ensues
yeah zaniness right yes wild antics
uh and and very you know uh was it
arnold schwarzenegger he does great job
as like
both a big muscle man and also just kind
of like
confused and and plays
the straight man quite well in that
regard yeah
so let's go to truth because we're
running a little late
well did you want to talk quickly about
uh one other dick thing which is the
the replicants and oh trade runner and
so you know blade runner always from the
you know the first one
um and the um
oh i'll not go into the book um the
first one with um harrison ford is rick
deckard as well as the the new one with
was ryan gosling as officer k um they're
both
uh yeah well i guess the question of the
first one is still up in the air
if if deckard is actually a replica is
he a replicant but
the second one you know it is played off
as uh officer pick a being a replicant
but then he starts to have memories of
things of a childhood and so he starts
to think that he might
not be a replicant and so um
he has these choils sorry these memories
of being a child that had a toy horse
and he hid it in a fireplace
um uh to hide it from some bullies that
wanted to take it from him and so
he's he's out on his on detective work
and he finds the fireplace and he
finds this horse from his childhood and
he believes that he may be in part human
because
how the heck could he have these
memories even though he knows that there
could be false memories
but there is a physical object that
actually corresponds with
his memories and it's like oh he
verifies things for him
right and so now he's going off this
idea that he is
at least partially human um the fact
that the physical world agrees with his
memory convinces
him that he is human and not just
replicant but
in the end this is a ruse the memory is
another's
and he found her horse believing it was
his
that's yeah what a kick in the pants i
mean right
we think our memories are so so much us
so
so intimate to us what if we did find
out that like the trip that i you know
like i took a trip with my dad to eagle
river when i was 10 you know for
fishing and all that what if that really
was some other
kid's memory that was given to me
because it was you know it was a really
great time and
you know it would be instead of an evil
evil
genius inventor it'd be like a benign
one he'd be like yeah
that sadler kid could need a little
pick-me-up let's give him the
the dad fishing trip memory
to find that out would really be um
a shock you know that it's not me and
not
not my myself even though i'm i'm so
distant from that little kid who is 10
years old
40 years that's 40 years ago you know
right
and it would be like once that happens
to you how can you
trust anything that you believe anymore
uh yeah that's a good question now would
it provoke like an
overall global skepticism
i don't know that it would for everybody
i think it would for some people they'd
be like well if i can't trust this i
can't trust anything else
and i can't trust anybody to give me the
the straight story on this but i think a
lot of people will be like uh that's an
aberration you know i'll
i'll just put that one over on the side
all my other stuff is okay
until it gets proven maybe three or four
times that the things that they thought
were
were heretical no longer are right
do you think that would be uh um
i mean might there be some people who
just never believe
oh yeah i believe like i think there's
people like that at the moment like they
they they totally think that you know
this is not like the reality that we're
living in
and everything is being like presented
to them
i don't know if they're like
neurotypical or anything along those
lines but
yeah well so you wanted to talk about
truth and
we might have to do a whole other
episode to get into some of the
theories of truth yeah oh go ahead
well as i was thinking like we we do we
were motivated so i'm just going back to
this a little bit about like
what why do we do the things we talked
about this um a bit
with the across the episode this whole
idea that people do what they believe to
be
is the good but if we don't have a good
memory about things
uh we can be led to bad decisions and so
the
our idea of the good is based off of
memory that is falsifiable
and and potentially uh manipulated to a
certain extent
and so how can you know what the good is
this often happens with generalizing too
much from one
one memory right so i'll give you sort
of a trivial example
you go to a restaurant and you order a
dish that you haven't had before
and it comes out and it's just like
amazing right
and you have no idea that they just
happen to have the good chef on that
night and it was served at just the
right time and temperature and
everything else was going for you
that evening you're with somebody that
you like and so you're like oh man that
was so amazing i'm going in and having
that
next week and you do and you get it and
it's it's
it's not so good you know it's it's not
terrible but it's not
it's not what you remember and you're
like did i get that wrong
i think that was really tasty but here's
the thing in front of me and it's just
not so hot and you could do this so
easily with you know people say oh first
impressions are so important
maybe first impressions shouldn't be
that important because we often
we generalize about people on the basis
of first impressions
i know i've done this many many times
where i'm like well that person's a jerk
you know and it just turns out they were
just having a bad day and distracted you
know
or i'm like well that person's cool and
it turns out that they're a jerk
you know yeah one should never make
total conclusions off of one data point
exactly yeah yeah maybe maybe that's the
better way to think about it in terms of
data points right
um as soon as you frame it like that
that calls for having more of them
and it prioritizes putting together like
a
a composite picture rather than just
going off of a sample of one you know
yeah
i guess it depends on like what you have
to do
uh i guess like if you're like hiring
someone and you're like how do you
how do you get enough data points from a
group of people to even decide to like
move them on to the next round like
obviously that's right that's an
interesting one
too because when you have like a a
committee to do hiring right
and you you like somebody comes in gives
a presentation they do their song and
dance they they leave
and then like okay we're all gonna like
reconvene
tomorrow and talk about this person this
candidate
and sometimes you're like did we all see
the same person
you know memories of who they were
changed quite a bit like some people
think that the person was taller than
they
they were you know other people are like
oh their presentation was amazing and
you're like i don't remember that you
know
yeah um hey at least for
like you people have thousands of hours
they can watch this like this see a good
teacher or not
but how much work are you going to put
into like i'm going to watch a
representative sample of greg sanders
lectures and make sure that i have a
really fully understood
you know idea that is a whole other can
of worms
and i'll just say this and then we
should do our practice because we're
getting
close on time so there are more hours
now
of people watching me then i have lived
like
you know way way more at this point in
time the last time i looked there were
like a hundred
hundred and two thousand hours or
no whatever it is it's it's longer than
it's like years and years and years like
100 years of
of that guy on the youtube videos
but he only does a very limited
repertoire of stuff he gets up in front
of a chalkboard every once in a while
like sits in a chair in front of
books he talks about some very limited
topics right
every once in a while there'll be a
video about my cat or things like that
but for the most part it's all like
explaining philosophy
and i've often thought so i'm just going
to throw this idea out there and see
what you think of this that if if
somebody wanted to
you you know put together like deep fake
and uh
ai stuff they could so easily mine my
youtube channel
take um all that that that data the
visual data
all the semantic data let's call it and
just glom it together
and have some character
that they could call dr gregory b sadler
just going on and on and on about
philosophy and it probably wouldn't be
great
you know it wouldn't have the
spontaneity that i have and it might
actually get some stuff wrong because
you know ais are good when it comes to
certain things i think when it comes to
philosophy and philosophical
this discourse there we're decades away
from that but
you could you could do something like
that and it could me maybe
he'd be like a philosophical comedian or
something like that you know right
um and and i'm surprised nobody's
actually done it yet
because that guy would would he wouldn't
he could
make money for them right um they could
charge for his classes and stuff like
that
and not pay me a cent yeah
quickly they did actually make a uh
animatronic version of philip k dick
based on his writings and all of his on
uh diaries and so you can ask him
questions and he would respond
as philip k dick in those responses very
interesting that's really interesting
because
he has a a novel in which there's an
entire school like that the martian time
slip
you know um and actually speaking of
philip k dick i don't think we're gonna
actually get to our practice
because we're running a bit short on
time but you know he's
when it comes to memory uh like dan was
saying he's definitely
his stories he more maybe than any other
sci-fi author has thematized all sorts
of interesting
aspects about memory maze of death would
be another great novel to check out
in that respect as well but there was a
great concept that dan was going to take
you
out on so i'm going to just turn it over
to you and let you riff with it
we leave you here today with the words
of philip q dick
reality is that which when you stop
leaving it
it doesn't go away
[Music]
[Music]
you